[Music]
in our school matters series we're
looking at how the pandemic has changed
the college admissions process
about 600 schools including ivy league
schools did not require
s-a-t or a-c-t scores in this year's
applications and as a result the number
of applications
skyrocketed applications sent in through
the common app
jumped 11 from the year before and that
app is now accepted by more than 900
schools we are joined now by jeff
selingo who wrote who gets in and why
a year inside college admissions is
published by scribner
an imprint of simon schuster which is
part of the wider viacom cbs company
jeff good morning to you
i'm really excited to talk to you this
morning because i remember sweating
the sats when i was in high school and
now colleges are not
accepting it or not requiring it anyway
could we be seeing the
end of standardized testing as we know
it
well the head of the a.c.t basically
said that we're not going back to
standardized testing the way that we had
it so 600 schools win test optional most
of them have extended it for another
year so for the
high school class of 2022 but what we're
seeing at many of the colleges that i
talk to that are kind of new to
to the test optional movement is that
even without test scores
they still basically accept it more
students who
came with test scores than those without
so if you're applying to a highly
selective college
even you know even without test scores
it still helps
if you can get one and you did well on
that on that test
if you did well it's always nice to show
it but if you didn't do well i like that
there's still a chance
uh you mentioned uh exception there's
still a chance
acceptance rates uh harvard has an
all-time low acceptance rate this year
of
3.4
that is very thin but you say that these
colleges and universities should not
necessarily be proud of those low rates
why not
no i mean harvard rejected 55 000
students this year they only
they have a class of like 1600 with a 42
billion dollar endowment they can easily
expand and in fact over the last 30
years
the ivy league as a whole only expanded
by about 14 percent their freshman class
while the number of high school
graduates grew by 44
wow so it's clear that what we learned
in this past pandemic year
is that not only can we perhaps do more
online
but that we could change the calendar so
that some students could go
through the summer some students could
go through fall break or winter break so
these schools can easily serve more in
fact we just saw rice university
announced
two weeks ago that they're going to
expand their freshman class by 20
so these schools can do it there are
hundreds of thousands of
kids i would say hundreds of thousands
of families because the whole family
really is on tender hooks because
they're on a wait list right now they do
not know where they're going to be going
in the fall
if anywhere is there anything that
people can do
when they're on a wait list to help
their chances
well the waitlist is a bit of a misnomer
because most of these colleges build the
wait list
into their enrollment model so they're
actually
accepting fewer students and putting
more of them on the waitlist because
they like to have students waiting in
the wings and that's especially
this year with so many applications many
of these schools don't really know how
serious these students are
so if you're on the wait list the odds
of getting off of it i must say are
pretty long
so you know make sure you have use that
as your your plan b
but you know send a note to the to the
school if your counselor if something
has changed in your application
tell them what has changed but don't
resubmit an entire application
and definitely have a backup plan of a
place that you actually got into that
you want to go to
or maybe even trade school still an
option all right jeff thank you very
much no one knows more about the process
than you
uh we appreciate it you check out the
book who gets in and why
a year inside the college admissions
process we appreciate you being on